and while players play this on let's
head over to the fuja board because
we're getting a big update that F Ali
Raza made a mistake okay so they' got
into two seconds did you see that
another move made with just one second
on the clock had the two seconds Sam
saan this time he made it we yesterday
blundered and lost on time up an
exchange up an exchange and queen G5 it
looks like Sam's in the driver's seat on
this one especially with the yeah
especially with the C4 and D5 in other
words when you put your Bishop on on uh
D4 I will play F6 you'll sacrifice your
Bishop but then I have t and we Ali Raz
a my pick he slips down the leaderboard
with that l